let me introduce myself first
my name is ijulu i am a user interface
developer
in wolfram research so today i'm going
to
talk about some of the uh
updates of existing feature and some of
the enhanced
um and some of the
uh performance of optimizations
i'm going to talk about some of texture
updates
shading updates and we have some
3d rotation gesture improvements and
and also the 3d notebook scoring and the
loading and we
also improved a little bit the
3d bonding range with a visible
rendering to reduce the white space
uh in the default case and also head
testing
printing rendering performance
improvements there are quite a few
uh finally i'm i'm going to talk about
uh
the uh updates of surface appearance
so texture we have
extended our texture to uh
quite a few more 3d primitives in 12 1
and
in 12 2 we're going we're also keeping
extended to
uh two more primitive rectangular discs
since currently texture objects is being
redesigned
so currently by default it's not
available but
you can still still access it through
source experience so here's the example
of the rectangle
uh the vertex texture according is
applying to the
rectangle um it works with
different options of the rounding radius
you can i just rotate it
you can scaling it
here's an example of disk you have the
flexibility
of defining the part of the
disk and also apply
transformation to it um
shading we same we introduced a bunch of
shading and failing into a one
to have the mpi rendering
capability and the intro to also add the
three more
fillings which is linear grid gradient
filling
uh radar gradient filling and kind of
creative filling
as uh let's first look at
the linear grid gradient filling as the
name
indicates you can interpolate
uh doing the linear interpolation so
you can give the scale the value
and each position you specify different
colors to it and it will interpolate
um other than that you can also uh
okay um
the dynamic okay um
so um it will
uh the the second argument is that angle
you can also
uh rotate it and also
you can also extend as a third argument
is extension
um let me see if this
evaluates
okay um
let me try a different color color
see
okay um let me switch to my
debug build i think there's something
wrong
with the current
mathematic i'm using um
okay oh
okay let's continue so
um let's come back to the linear
gradient filling
okay okay so yeah
i think there are some bugs there and
we are fix that so uh let's go to the
examples
um so if
the the um
um it should currently spoken it should
work
with different color data
um let's see if i do different
number uh yeah
it worked with that all the color data
and you can also specify the
uh different color space
uh for example you can do the rgb color
space and also
the um the you convert it to
lab color space the the things
difference is if you are using lab color
space if you are going to
interpolate in lab space instead of rgb
space
um it should like other shadings and
feelings it should work with
uh work with all the plots
and all the bar charts so
um yeah 3d rotation
so um we
uh the the default arc ball is the
default gesture
for graphics um but
it has a limitation that it only limited
within the binding box if the mouse
moving outside
uh the bounding box and the the rotation
stops
this makes the control of uh a long
thing object
rotating that being difficult
but now in in the new version 12 2 we
extended it
it so that it go
outside and it continues
and also we improved that
that the sometimes it has some
image size jump and
[Music]
we have been improved so that it jumps
slowly instead of sudden jump
and meantime also we are uh
added and several new outboard gestures
for experiment
so for example this one is has both x y
direction control
um for uh so like uh
if you rotate this you don't need to
stop if you
move to vertical space it will just
respect
at any position
um the current
one is is does not do x y
direction a reference back to the
original position so that it'll come
back
to uh the original camera if you move
back
um but the this one is the the the one
we're experimenting with is
it it gives users more control that
we're rotating it just uh respects the
both x
y uh direction um
uh notebook scoring we did some
optimization of
mg cache and
there are uh there are fixed view issues
so that to make sure that
the uh image cache has been maximally
uh reused so for for example uh
before i had a 69
a 69 3d testing cases
um some some of the case containing
uh rust video which is supposed to be
expensive
but uh it was only saved like a five
image cache
and now it saves more for those cases
so you can imagine that the loading
speed of that
it should be improved and
and also screwing the
that notebook containing a lot of 3d
graphics
it will be it will be much faster
because it has been a maximum they reuse
energy cache
um bonding range some of you have
already used the
shrink wrap to cut the white space
so you might wondering where are those
white space coming from in the default
case
um so we are doing uh
for performance reasons we don't want to
project all the
uh points to compute the visible
area because the it could there could be
millions points there and we don't want
to make
our uh rotation uh much slower
um so we did before we did a binding box
computing and project those
binding blocks but now in the new
version we're
also computing the binding sphere and
binding cylinder so you can see
the the spherical
or ceiling shape like a cylinder
objects will be um
much tighter and uh compared to
the neutral one and other objects could
also have some
some benefits of that and here is uh
example
of of uh some
uh round like objects
you can see um they
some of the cases they might have still
have some
but it's getting improved and without no
much
performance cost
heat testing what is heat testing heat
testing
has been used for uh
for all selection interaction
and uh and it could be very expensive if
there's a
uh millions objects there in the single
box
and so how do we optimize them
and uh we're now using a culture what is
culture
cultures uh split your
space into uh for
subspace and keep going on and depends
on the
the objects you have
so uh of course we cannot do uh
uh like uh uh
uh so for example if there's only one
object we don't need to do
multiple layers of of these
nested necessary so how do we determine
the next level
um considering there are the the
object most of the objects are uniformly
distributed
on the on the on the screen so we're
using
uh the log 10
of the num object number for example
like a half million
objects if we're using five level
so the leaf is roughly about a thousand
uh quad trees there and uh
if there are distributed uh
roughly uniformly so each box
each culture will contain about
uh 500 object
so so so then when you uh
doing clicking and selecting it will
just
only look at uh to the right
quality the sub quality and do the
minimize the computing thus you can
and uh improve the performance
for this example this is the less dense
city plot
example from user contains
0.6 objects triangles there
and so originally you have to do
uh 0.6 testing to go through all the
objects
and but now you only
need to do like a 900 testing it's
roughly
a thousand times
much less and
so for this example and
i this makes the editing of the large
data set and
the interactivity of large dataset
possible
um i
i tried this on 121 on my
laptop it it has been taking like a half
an hour it's not
responding it's because of the rendering
and the the head testing
it's going back and forth it's kind of
like a dead loop
has has some interfere with each other
but
you can do this now with the improve the
uh testing performance we do the same
thing for
3d as well here is example
um it's a two service
each service contains 0.5 million
objects
and so each object will contain five
level
oak tree um actually is a little bit uh
z direction it has a has a
four more sub trees as well so
uh you can think each
sub tree it might contain like a 200
objects but the since it's in 3d is some
of the
some of the quality uh my overlapping
depths
so roughly it
reduced to 200 to 700 heat tests
so still roughly it's a thousand times
of time optimization so
as you can see it's much faster in 1202
and because of this testing optimization
we can do more precise
uh distance computing so that
we know exactly which object we hit
which exact triangle we hit
and then it gives the right response
printing um since version
six introduced we have been using mace
software mesa for printing
uh on all platforms um
the reason for that is it it it will
interfere with the on screen
otherwise it will interfere with
on-screen rendering
and we don't want that and in
12-2 we figured that out and then
so uh the the we are now using hardware
printing
driver hardware soft hardware driver for
printing
this should affect all 3d graphics or
a subset of 2d graphics printing same
as pdf or other image formats or if you
want to copy to other applications like
mail or paint i have some
rough number i randomly selected a
133 testing graphics
um there are several raster 3d and also
2d graphics as well
takes 40 minutes to saving as
a pdf and now only takes 35 seconds
that's the difference between the
hardware driver
printing and also the the missile
and other than the printing performance
improvements we also did
several rendering performance
improvements as well
uh remember we mentioned the graphics
cache
and we did that for 2d as well and
so for those like uh
the not necessary case not expensive
case we
just uh we don't do the image
cache so this improves the performance
um of of the 2d graphics manipulate
animate dynamic if it has a large
image um the more the bigger the image
of science you said
the bit more difference you will notice
that
so now in the performance the general
performance
uh of manipulate and uh and
animate and with those graphics will be
uh
improved there by front
uh 15 to 33 roughly
40 percent
and if i show the
the frame rate you can see
um um it will
currently it's running uh other
application if we just run this example
you will see
um the uh the frame rate
jump to 23.
and vertex 2d polygon with vertex color
this is the case used by most
visualization functions through the
color function case
and we also optimize that this is the
same example
i showed you before before it takes
uh like uh roughly four seconds
uh to to render the first time and the
same
after and uh now it only takes point six
sec uh run the first time and then it
will
like take only 0.5 seconds after
um this is roughly
six to eight times uh performance
improvements
is this should have affect all the uh
function all the visualization
functions plots with color function
um the larger
image and if you like zoom in large
image
and the rest 3d the performance has been
improved as well um
before even with the uh clip range
it's the the invisible
and the invisible pixels steer
somewhere there still is quite expensive
and we're now doing the visibility check
and only jaws are visible
so if the performance now improve their
roughly from 0.6 to 13
frame rate and uh it
should be much faster geometry
transformation
we optimize this is a very uh widely
used
uh example i mean
here is a list of like a 25 by 25 by 25
cubes there
um the the performance has
been improved from 1.5 to
27 and it's also
roughly 20 times performance improvement
we with
if before we had some problems with
combining rust 3d or immediately
together with other transparency objects
now we're doing a new message called
bonded volume rendering
so since casts seems like this
um if you want to combine
uh images video together with other
uh transparent object it will be much
faster
now roughly it's like four to
roughly four times faster
surface appearance we did have
some several updates and uh so now it
could take
uh uh gls along file directly
and just place it in the in the working
directory
and and specify to to the
right fragment program and vertex
program
and let i i
take some example from some this online
resource and this is quite simple and
when you look at that it just makes use
of the
vertex and and and
vertex textures and
to make it work you uh you just need to
tell tell our uh experience that you're
going to use the vertex
position and the vertex texture
coordinates of course you need the
transformation as well
and yeah it has a transformation as well
so
so specific that specify that and
it will just work with
um
[Music]
let me take a look
okay um yeah i believe the same same
reason as
uh as the the the surface
the the the fillings uh the broken i
think there are some something wrong
with my build
and but uh yeah so
um roughly it just
you give this piece and it just works
and you can also try it
with um other resources like
um like some this
uh on this website it gives a list of
like a digital arts and it also has the
jio slang uh source code there you can
just uh
took it and notice that only
has two parameters here times and
resolution and
and we can reuse our
vertex vertex shader and also
the the the feeding in the new
fragment program you found and uh
give the two perm give the the
define the two uh parameters time as a
resolution
and it should just works
um i
i think
let me try and see
what's going on here
um yeah i think yeah there's something
wrong with my build
so um so
yeah so mod graphics talks we uh james
lee were
talking about some new and experimental
features for 12
202 and that's right after this talk
and uh so yeah so
uh that's a talk and
let me see if there's some questions
okay yeah so okay that's it
thanks bye